111 ans et huit mois
jeanne calment en est la doyenne des
français cela ne l'impressionnent pas
elle trouve tout à fait normal d'avoir
cet âge légèrement sourde des
difficultés de vision jeanne calment
respire la joie de vivre
bonne vivante et pleine d'humour cette
vieille dame coupe depuis un an des
jours heureux dans une maison de repos
d'arles
après avoir connu tant de choses dans sa
vie j'ai connu bistrot et gecko les
vitraux litres à cette partie des sommes
assez désagréable lorsqu'il est réglé et
baldas yeux sur le caractère parce qu'il
venait il venait au magasin pour acheter
étoiles pour sa table ou alors comme il
fallait que je regrette de tout âge il
était très difficile alors comme ça
c'était les gens travaillent et y les
remballer les gros il veut déjà payé
vous servir et conseille d'arriver il
prenait la tangente
alors c'était barriques et les chairs et
8 des patients à des turcs est toute une
dégradation dès qu'ils allaient ton fai
sai t t au et de monsieur mitterrand
l'avait quelle image c'est-à-dire qu'ils
avaient caractère de la riche c'est le
sur le prototype de la ruche patience et
longueur de temps font plus que force et
d'éclairage et à patience j'ai réussi un
peu tard mais il est arrivé savent c'est
vraiment le type prototype du et
l'enrichissent état il est un dieu je
vous lis et en dehors d'une cigarette
par jour après le repas le péché mignon
de jeanne calment ce sont les chocolats
[Musique]